et faut-il envisager d re confinement
l'eau qu'on veut en débattre tout de
suite avec nos invités bertrand legrand
médecins généralistes et noël à jour y
président de l'union des métiers et des
industries de l'hôtellerie est de calme
bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors un
confinement locale est-ce que c'est
incontournable
au vu de la situation dans le
département bertrand legrand
on a un département sur nice qui a des
couteaux de contamination record on
avait vécu la même chose à roubaix lors
de la deuxième vague
après ça dépend essentiellement des
capacités des hôpitaux à prendre en
charge ces malades
à partir du moment où ils seront
débordés il n'y a pas vraiment d'autre
choix pour stopper le la progression de
l'épidémie qu de confiner mais encore
une fois le confinement est toujours la
solution d'un échec des prévention en
amont noël à jour y d'abord votre
réaction sur ce qui vous attend
c'est parce que nous attentions en le
sait pas malheureusement ce soir
monsieur le préfet devait annoncer les
décisions prises entre la préfecture et
matignon
apparemment ils se sont pas mis d'accord
au l'instant il a remis ça à demain mais
de fait et qu'il a remis ça à demain à
mon avis il est dès 6 ans vont être plus
sévère on s'attend à décider des
décisions plus sévères pour demain vous
pensez que ça va être encore plus sévère
réellement bertrand legrand est ce qui a
été annoncé c'est à dire au confinement
localiser confinement le week-end
couvre-feu renfort fait en fait la
difficulté c'est de savoir quelles sont
les mesures qui vont permettre de
limiter réellement la propagation
on a vu en septembre on est passé de
quel d'une 14/n à sept jours de comptes
de confinement pour les personnes qui
étaient positives depuis cette prise de
décision qui a eu lieu en septembre
le plateau n'est jamais vraiment
redescendue et donc on a eu une deux
vague qui a monté très fortement mais
qui n'est pas redescendue et
probablement que le passage de 7 jours à
10 jours à devrait améliorer un petit
peu la propagation mais si on continue à
ne pas isoler les personnes positives et
qu'on laisse passer 5 à 10% de la de
l'infection on a forcément non retour à
zéro
la véritable question ne s'est pas
vraiment le confinement est la véritable
question c'est faisons-nous ce qu'il
faut pour isoler les personnes positives
et la réponse est clairement non nous
faisons tout ce qu'il faut pour renvoyer
des personnes positives au travail le
plus vite possible au prix d'une
contamination qui va être résiduelles
vous êtes d'accord noël à jour et on
sait pas assez préparée en amont et on
ne fait pas ce qu'il faut est tout à
fait on sait pas ce qu'il faut mais moi
je pense qu'il faut arrêter de jouer au
yoyo avec et ce virus confinement pas
confinement fermeture à 18h par
fermeture à 18h pourquoi ne pas prendre
une décision ferme et profiter de ses
vacances scolaires pendant les 15 jours
moi je parle pour les alpes maritimes
après chaque département prendra les
décisions qu'il faut mais pour les
alpes-maritimes pourquoi ne pas prendre
cette décision là surtout que cet après
midi le maire de lys qui est le
président de la métropole a annoncé qu'
on a eu cet après-midi 17 de nouveaux
cas d'hospitalisation et les pour
répondre aux médecins et que les
services en sursaturé et depuis deux
trois jours il commence à envoyer des
malades dans d'autres hôpitaux
pourquoi ne pas fermer vraiment l'isu la
côte d'azur pendant ces quinze jours et
qu'on arrête avec ce virus et qu'on
arrête de jouer
au yoyo un jour oui un jour non je sais
que c'est très difficile d'accepter
aussi une fermeture comme ça surtout
pour les quelques restaurateurs qui
vivre encore de des plats à emporter ou
des livraisons c'est pas évident pour
eux de fermer de prendre une décennie la
décision du jour au lendemain mais si
c'est pour le bond de la société si
c'est pour le bon pour pour le
département et n'oubliez pas que on est
un cas un mois de pâques on aura les
vacances de pâques bientôt aussi on aura
le mois de mai et tout le monde le sait
que le mois de mai on a des week-end et
le week-end qu'est ce qu'on fait de
toutes ces vacances là on va jouer
continue à jouer comme ça on ferme à
wigan ont fait un ouvre le soir on ferme
le midi c'est pas c'est pas facile c'est
pas facile pour tout le monde pour les
civils que pour les commerçants
comment on explique noël à jour est la
situation aujourd'hui des alpes
maritimes où le taux d'incidence dépasse
700 pour 100000 habitants très loin
devant la moyenne nationale on a perdu à
l'instant bertrand legrand noël à jour y
en ait toujours avec vous justement la
population comment est ce qu elle peut
accueillir ces nouvelles mesures si les
mesures deviennent plus sévères que ce
qu'elles ne sont actuellement
est ce que vous pensez qu elles ont
accepté ces restrictions supplémentaires
mais ça va être difficile mais dans
votre reportage tout à l'heure où dans
les reportages que jerry toute la
journée avec les les gens si à nice il
ya là beaucoup qui sont pauvres un
confinement total et qu'on arrête de
parler de decaux vide
on est à la proche du printemps quand je
dis et je le répète on est on a les
vacances scolaires maintenant on a pas
que dans un mois on a le mois de mai est
la saison où démarre maintenant
normalement la saison démarre maintenant
avec lui au carnaval de nice qui a été
annulée cette année malheureusement et
on peut pas continuer comme ça
faisons de sorte de confinés pendant 15
jours ou semaines s'il faut une semaine
tant pis si ça suffit une semaine une
semaine mais il faut il faut fermer et
être sûr de ce qu'on fait parce que là
le fermeture pour moi des fermes de la
fermeture du week-end ça va pas suffire
pourquoi parce que de lundi à vendredi
on laisse les gens sortir aller dans les
centres commerciaux allaient faire leurs
courses et tout ça et le virus continue
à se propager et le week end
vous pensez que le week end le virus il
va s'arrêter on va dire cédric halde
tudor au virus et et d'une laisse
tranquille parce que nous on va rester à
la maison
moi je pense pas bon vous pensez la
campagne de vaccination elle progresse
le gouvernement promet qu'en tout cas
d'ici quelques mois les choses devraient
rentrer dans l'ordre même si elle j'ai
du retard
l'exécutif qui a promis que d'ici la fin
de l'été on devrait tous être vaccinés
ou penser que le gouvernement essaie de
gagner du temps puisque même ce soir on
attendait les annonces avait dit que ce
serait demain 1 le préfet qui doit se
prononcer sur un éventuel confinement
localiser le week end
tout à fait et tout le monde
on entend tout le monde les politiques
surtout les politiques nous donne
l'exemple d'israël
c'est très bien chapeau pour ce pays là
qui a su gérer la crise mais en israël
si on prend le cas d'israël qu'est ce
qu'ils ont fait ils ont fermé le pays en
imposant un troisième confinement et ils
ont accéléré la vaccination est
aujourd'hui le pays a réouvert depuis ce
matin je crois si je me trompe pas
depuis ce matin et les restaurateurs
vont commencer à ouvrir à partir de
début mars le 7 mars aussi mais c'est
très bien ça c'est une très bonne
nouvelle pour ce pays là qui a su gérer
la crise en confinant et en accélérant
la vaccination et les cartes avec un
pass justement pour permettre aux
personnes déjà vaccinées de pouvoir
sortir se rendre pendant les yeux un peu
de convivialité
d'autres un exemple à suivre c'est un
fait pardon c'est un exemple à suivre
mais pourquoi pas
son sens nous donner au resto à moi je
parle pour les restaurateurs et les
hôteliers sont nous donner le rôle des
douaniers parce qu' un certain moment on
a parlé d'un système à l'entrée des
établissements chez nous pour faire un
peu près ce que le douanier on le
policier on n'est pas d'accord mais un
impasse vert comme on israel pourquoi
pas c'est très bien et qu'on le mette en
place et qu'on applique et je suis sûr
que d'ici cet été
le pays revient à la normale peut-être
par action pour cent mais mais en moi on
retrouve nos établissements en gros on
retrouve la joie de vivre autour de nos
plats autour de l'établissement
les brasseries les terrasses que surtout
quand on va dans vers le printemps vers
le breton regardez vos je vois l'image
sur votre écran de nice aujourd'hui on à
lui à un soleil il a fait je crois qu'à
ce degré on a eu un soleil magnifique et
comme je disais tout à l'heure
la saison démarre maintenant pour nous
pour la côte et sur la côte d'azur aussi
on fait pas attention on va louper et la
saison et on va louper peut-être jusqu'à
la fin de l'année on va rester comme ça
à monter et à descendre à fermer à
ouvrir donc vous vous seriez en
favorable à un confinement localiser
tout à fait tout à fait sains mais un
vrai confirmant un vrai confirmant son
dire on ferme le samedi soir jusqu'à
lundi matin et on laisse les gens faire
n'importe quoi en semaine elle est comme
je vous ai dit faire les courses aller
dans les centres commerciaux
elle est sur les marchés
et à droite à gauche non en prenant la
décision ferme une décision ferme de
faire un confinement ferme vraiment
sévère comme ce qu'on a eu au début de
la crise l'année dernière en mars
l'année dernière et je suis sûr qu'on
arrivera bien sûr en parallèle il faut
continuer avec l'accélération de
vacciner les gens merci beaucoup à vous
noël la jouerie je rappelle que vous
êtes président de l'union des métiers
des industries de l'hôtellerie de canon
va remercier aussi bertrand legrand
qu'on a perdu médecins généralistes